Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
June 30th,
2014.
Um,
what's going on?
I am a,
I am in Las Vegas,
Nevada.
I had a wonderful weekend out here at the Mirage casita um,
I want to thank everybody who came down to the shows.
It was a wonderful time.
Everybody seemed to enjoy themselves.
Um,
and I'm out of here right now because,
uh,
the all in tour starring Jason Law,
Joe Part Nick and uh,
Paul New Jersey Versie um,
was at,
uh,
was over at Harris and I stopped in last night as I said that I would and all
red face jumped up on stage in the end throughout our new 15,
20 minutes.
All right.
I already got one new bit.
I got one new bit for my,
uh,
my next hour,
that I'm already loving and that I'm adding to it.
And I'm literally,
you know what's hilarious is cause I don't have any material now technically,
um,
once my,
you know,
all that other shit that I just did is gone.
So anything that I'm even seeing remotely funny,
I'm just fucking latching onto.
And so I was doing a lot of people watching last night and I was just
desperately just anything I could think of like I fucking saw.
But even even I got to draw a line somewhere cause I like,
I saw this,
uh,
this woman was walking through the bar at this casino we were at.
And uh,
we over it seizes and um,
she's walking through the bar and there's gay do with sandals jeans in this
really fucking,
I thought it was an ugly tank top,
whatever.
He sees her and I guess they're friends and he fucking freaks out.
Oh my God.
Runs over and fucking gives me this huge hug.
I was literally like,
you know what,
I want to gate front,
you know,
somebody gets said fuck it.
Excited when I walk into a room,
you know.
And that was really like,
oh dude,
I should talk about that.
I just talk.
But then I actually had to stop myself just going,
all right bill,
you know what?
Every stupid little thought you have does not need to go to the stage.
And then I argued with myself yet does get does cause I just burned fucking 90
minutes a shit.
I need that.
I need that bit.
I've already fucking,
I know another little half ass idea.
Holy Shit.
Somebody just scored a goal.
Sorry in the background I have on France versus uh,
some team in lime green.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
the fuck am I doing?
I really shouldn't have that on.
And you know,
I have it on in the background cause I thought the USA was playing Belgium
today.
They thought it was fucking Tuesday
and I can't keep track of fucking anything.
I,
I have no idea.
I just really have to give it to the fact that,
uh,
as much as I respect the sport,
I just,
um,
okay.
I don't know.
I'm too busy to figure out what's going on.
But uh,
the big deal,
the big deal this week is tomorrow.
You know,
you guys for a long time,
well I can't say alia,
but a fuel,
you've asked me to go and do it.
Why don't you do a live podcast.
Wouldn't that be cool?
I would love to see a live recording of the Monday morning podcast and uh,
my thing has always been like,
look,
you really don't want to see me just lying on a fucking couch.
Okay.
And God damn jam jams.
Like I even wear those.
I don't,
you know,
just lying here recording a podcast,
it's going to be boring as shit.
And then I'm also going to have to,
um,
I'm going to have to like address the crowd.
It don't think seems weird.
However,
I am not against co hosting a podcast,
which is what I'm going to be doing for the first time ever,
ever.
I'm going to be co hosting a live podcast for the all things comedy network at
Nerd Melt on sunset boulevard.
Uh,
I'll have the link up and everything,
um,
on the uh,
on the podcast page and also we'll have it up on the Twitter account at m pot,
the [inaudible] podcast and it's going to be Tuesday night,
July 1st I think it's an APM is able to do so.
Let me click on the link here,
but it's going to be me and Al Madrigal and bringing on a bunch of guests from
the all things comedy a network.
We're also going to be having an auction
to raise money for some shit.
I don't know what the hell it is.
And it's just basically personal items that all these Comedians,
oh and myself included.
I think I'm donating a hockey stick
and whatever the fuck you want to give us,
we don't give a shit.
You'll be actually be able to call in.
We'll actually going to have callers.
We're going to be having live,
uh,
you know,
you can text us like a real radio show.
Um,
well it says it's going to start in one day,
11 hours and 36 minutes.
Jesus Christ.
She just have what time it's on.
How does that know?
How the fuck does that help me?
Okay.
I can do the math.
It's eight o'clock,
eight o'clock tomorrow at nerd melt.
July 1st.
Okay.
And I think it's very,
very fitting that we're having it during the week of this nation's birthday,
July 4th.
I'm so everybody come down.
Um,
if you want to bid on the,
uh,
the shit that we're going to be selling,
um,
by all means do that.
If you don't get it,
whatever,
just come on down and have a good time.
Come down and watch the live broadcast.
And,
uh,
I'm really looking forward to it because as of
tomorrow that that begins my vacation where I'm taking off the fucking summer,
I'll be going on hikes,
trying to get a few more freckles.
Um,
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I'm not gonna be doing shit,
but,
uh,
so anyways,
let's get back to this.
So I'm in Las Vegas right now and I have to tell you,
the landscape of this town just keeps changing.
Like I didn't realize,
like out here right now,
you know that Dj Music
Damn Land Wa wa,
Wa,
Wa where we're Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
Oh my God.
Uh,
uh,
Ooh.
Oh,
that shit like is the biggest fucking thing ever
out here
in Las Vegas right now.
The highest paid entertainers are all those djs will bull we,
we'll pull up,
we'll wait for that shit
up here.
That shit is the biggest fucking thing.
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Pause
ball ball,
Bam.
Right.
We get a pill.
Okay.
Yes.
So that fucking shit
is huge.
There is literally out here at these,
these fucking clubs.
I mean these,
these uh,
these casinos are building these clubs.
They have more clubs than they actually have,
like legitimate DJ's.
Um,
and they are,
there was literally,
I was reading this thing,
a lot of literal stuff.
Bill,
we get it.
You're not lying to us.
I was reading this article
called Dj wars inside the Las Vegas battle for the world's top electric
electronic music talent.
Now these fucking guys like,
I don't know where any of them are cause I'm old Afro Jack.
Um,
Calvin Harris,
I don't know any of these guys are um,
a couple of their songs.
I've heard them though,
you know,
cause my wife watches keeping up with the Kardashians and shit and they're
always playing that in that than the Iranian one,
the Shahs of sunset.
Um,
where they got that dude,
the gay guy on that show looks like Freddy Mercury.
Fuck Joseph Stalin.
Okay.
Um,
it looks like gay Saddam Hussein is what he looks like.
He needs a fucking riot.
Um,
cause he's always stirring shit up between the ladies.
He absolutely loves it and he's so fucking passive aggressive.
It'll be like,
hey,
so what did parada say?
What'd she called you?
This what happened?
And then they just,
I'm doing yoga.
I'm doing a hacky gay accent.
He fucking,
uh,
I dunno,
whatever.
Stay on the topic bill.
So these fucking djs too,
like they're making
like,
what did they say?
Yeah,
yeah.
Which once was a hundred million dude,
that's it.
Whatever.
They're building these,
these clubs,
there's these giant like square rooms and they just pack in like 5,000,
6,000 young,
beautiful people and the dude or whatever,
I don't know if there's any women Djs,
has gotta be whatever the men and women Djs go up there and they're not just
playing records like I thought,
I guess that they come up with that shit.
They come up with that.
That's theirs.
That's not a sample.
Okay.
From like fucking John Lennon imitating one of the three stooges.
This,
this is their original shit.
So they fucking come up there.
They're famous Accra.
I know a lot of you guys already know this shit.
I know they are fucking world famous and they got to lug all their mixes and all
this shit around the world at giant mouse heads and all this stuff.
And they just take up.
They just go out there and they play this shit and then make it a zillion
dollars.
So anyways,
out here in Vegas,
that's how they're making all the money.
That's how they're packing out.
The casinos are,
uh,
are these djs and um,
they barely promote anything else.
I guess that is the deal.
But,
um,
they tried to say that the young kids don't really gamble and they just come out
and they get fucked up and they go to these DJ shows and um,
and they're able to make the money.
But this,
I don't want to name names,
I mean the article basically names names and says how much money they're making.
I think that's a little fucking tacky.
But they were saying one guy made like $58 million last year.
Okay.
Playing that shit to these,
to these kids and I got to tell you something.
If you're in a fucking casino
and they don't have that Dj music going on,
I swear to God like,
ah,
the casinos I was in last night at 46 years of age,
I was kind of like the youngest person in the casino.
It was fucking unreal.
I was looking around going like,
wait,
where are all the,
where is everybody?
It's just a bunch of old people just sitting there and,
uh,
I guess the raw,
they're all at these other casinos that have these,
these,
uh,
these Dj rumps.
So here's the funny thing,
the typical fucking thing.
So this is the,
so this is the big war now.
So all these fucking casinos are building these giant square rooms and then
they're,
they're fighting over,
you know,
the top Djs to get them there and they like doubling the asking prices and all
that.
It's going through the fucking roof.
And it's literally reminding of,
uh,
the standup comedy boom when they start,
when they,
cause like right now they have more rooms than they actually have legitimate
people that can fill up the rumps and they,
they pack in like five,
6,000 people a night.
Um,
but I guess that's down from like seven,
8,000.
And it's the exact same thing that,
um,
I can't say I saw it in stand up comedy,
but right when I started standup comedy,
I started in March in 1992.
Yeah,
I know I'm old.
Um,
they,
they had basically at that point the fallout had already begun from having more
comedy clubs.
Then you actually had comedians.
So what happens is obviously then you just start anybody with a pulse,
they just start sticking up there behind the microphone,
go and you know,
watch the deal with everything.
Right.
And um,
and the,
and it just went down the shitter and I just don't fucking get why they,
they,
they just,
they keep doing this.
It's like you've got a great thing.
Edm,
electronic dance music,
I guess is what it's called.
And uh,
well I guess,
yeah,
because if you don't have it,
there's a bunch of old people like me
at your fucking casino.
It's,
I've never seen the distance between young people and old people greater in the
entire time that have been coming out to Las Vegas,
which has been,
um,
since the late nineties.
I've never seen it bigger,
but used to see a decent mix of people in the casino and then like certain
places like the hard rock cafe,
casino,
whatever the fuck they call it,
that was like the place to go.
And you went in there and there was a bunch of young,
young kids in there and by kids I just meet people in their twenties.
Um,
but basically all the other ones were kind of like,
you know,
it was a decent fucking mix of people and there were people gambling and now I
don't know the tables and shit with dead.
Granted it's a fucked up time to come out here.
Hockey and basketball are over.
So a lot of the sports books are kind of drying up.
But like,
um,
it's going to be interesting to see when this bubble bursts exactly what is
going to happen and what the fuck they gonna they don't give a shit.
I was going to say what they were going to do with their rooms,
those giant square rooms,
what they can turn them into.
Um,
so right now,
yeah,
you basically have ventriloquists or that fucking that,
that,
uh,
Edm music out here and uh,
yeah,
I dunno man.
It's,
it's a,
uh,
I,
I just,
that,
that thing is going to,
that thing is going to fucking nose dive.
It's going to knows that.
I mean,
you gotta be thinking that as you just keep building another room.
We'll give him 50 mil,
we'll give them 60 million.
This is like what the red sox and Yankees did the next thing enough.
You know,
you got Eric gynae up their fucking way,
pa people bull pull,
well blah,
blah,
doing that shit.
Then it's over there.
One day somebody just stands back and goes,
what the fuck are we doing?
But you got to do it.
That's what you,
you know,
back when I was coming up,
it was that hair metal shit and everybody blew out their hair,
right?
Said something about the devil.
And then you had a little fucking ballad and then you shot the ballot right in
the ballad was always in black and white in the beginning.
And then when the guitar solo finally came in,
um,
that's when it went into color.
They just ride it into the fucking ground.
I think that's what you do on that side of the business.
You see a trend,
this is where the money's going and you just fucking jump on that horse.
You don't stop for water.
You just ride that thing until it fucking,
it dies.
Then you get off the fucking thing and you act like you,
you,
you never rode the horse
job.
Dude,
I don't know,
Edm.
I can't even listen to that shit even though you made like a zillion fucking
dollars off of it.
So,
uh,
I don't,
I know I'm obviously in way over my head here.
I don't know what I'm talking about,
but I found it really fascinating and I got to tell you,
I'm happy for all those Goddamn g Djs,
you know.
I mean,
you know what's great about their,
their uh,
they're like standup comedy bubble here.
This thing that they're fucking writing is they are making money.
They're going to be set for life.
All right?
So if there's any Goddamn djs listened to this fucking thing,
I better not see you on some behind the music thing,
talking about how you're blue.
You're $50 million a fucking year.
You should be set for life.
Okay?
Oh my God.
If I made 50 million in one fucking year,
you figure out,
right?
You got to,
you given away 10 year agent tender,
your manager,
that's 10 million,
now you're down to 40 million and the government's gonna come in and they're
going to fucking wacky for at least half that.
So you still got like 19 million bucks.
Just go out and just buy a $5 billion piece of per hour.
But then what he,
then he got to pay the property taxes on that
someday when the DJ shit ends
by like $1 million house and Allah fucking Bama,
right?
Go down there in Alabama where everything's fucking cheap or Arkansas or
something like that.
And just by yourself,
a big spread,
pay the fuck are rough.
And then when the whole thing goes into the shitter and nobody cares about that
music anymore cause it's,
you know,
you got to wait 20 years until it becomes cool again because it goes down the
shitter and then the next decade they got to have their own personality.
So they,
they got to hate on the,
the decade before.
But the decade before,
the decade before is always considered cool.
Right?
Like right now,
slowly the 90s are going to start coming back,
you know,
like in the nineties and the eighties when I was coming up,
everybody was into the 60s and everyone thought the 70 sucked with disco and
soft rock don't all that fucking shit.
And then in the 90s all of a sudden the 70s became cool again.
Right.
And there was all these movies like Boogie nights and all of that fucking stuff
and all this disco music that everybody loved and then hated.
Then they loved it again.
So uh,
this,
as I'm calling this right now,
like Paul brosy,
this Dj music is going to be considered the shit by a certain segment of the
population.
Okay.
In the 2027 and be like,
oh my God,
it's fucking awful.
Emperor's new clothes,
what was going on?
And everybody stood there with glow sticks pumping the fist and the fucking air
and then a,
the hipsters of the 2030 of the 30 step basically going to be like a,
I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck they going to do.
There'll be walking around with the mouse heads on,
on top of the fucking hence Gi bill.
That's really insightful.
So you mean like nothing's going to change in the future?
Yeah,
that's basically what I'm saying.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
if you're new to the podcast,
this is about as good as it gets.
I hate to tell you this is,
this is what I'm bringing to the table and um,
so if you want to leave,
I totally understand.
And with that,
let's read some advertising for this week.
What do we got here?
Oh,
we only got a couple slowly but surely pissing all of them off.
Can we get she,
can we get bill on the phone?
There was a few things that he said last week.
Can we get him on the phone?
No.
No you cannot.
You cannot get me on the phone cause it's my fucking podcast and that's why I do
this.
So I don't have a boss so I don't have to get on the phone.
You,
you want,
you write it on a fucking posted and you let me know what you didn't like and
then I won't read it.
All right.
Hulu plus everybody you've probably tried,
I don't know.
I thought it said Hitler.
The hell is I got a learning disability.
You've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch current EP,
but current season episodes of your favorite shows like modern family do.
What if they had Hitler plus,
you know for people who Hitler.
Was it enough?
Dude,
I'll do you one better.
I don't think that guys got far enough introducing Hitler plus.
All right,
let's start this one over again.
Who Blew Hulu plus everyone.
You've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch current season episodes
of your favorite shows like modern family,
the daily show and scandal and watch every of shows like Nashville loss in
doctor who um,
you get ad free movies and kid shows to now more than ever,
there's so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu.
Plus you can stream these shows and thousands more as much as you want,
wherever you want.
Hulu plus works on your computer,
smart TV,
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox,
playstation.
Pretty much any streaming device you already own.
You can watch any damn show you want as long as it's on Hulu.
Plus this thing is great.
You could even watch on your phone or iPad while on the train,
while at work at the dentist or at the bathroom in the bathroom.
Sorry.
You can even block off a day to binge.
Basically you,
you,
you never have to.
You know,
if you're traveling and you're favorite team is playing,
you can watch.
It's phenomenal.
You get access to originals that you can't get anywhere else.
Check out the new show.
Deadbeat a comedy about a pot smoking guy who talks to ghosts.
Binge on all 10 episodes starting April 9th for Ali,
seven 99 a month.
Get your shows anytime,
anywhere.
That's like a quarter a day right now.
Sign up at Hulu plus.com/burpee you are R and get two weeks full access,
completely free.
Um,
this,
that's a whole extra week more with this special offer when you sign up at Hulu
plus.com/bill uh,
or Burr,
I don't know what it is cause they keep telling me norm with this copy,
why do I keep getting nor Mcdonald's coffee?
So get with it and start streaming TV with Hulu plus.
Alright,
stamps.com everyone computers are designed to make running a business easier,
including your mailing and shipping.
Just use stamps.com to to get 24 hours access to the post office right from your
computer.
No waiting in line.
No Hassles,
man.
stamps.com makes mailing and shipping easy.
Just use the computer and the printer that you already have to get official US
postage for any letter,
any package.
Print the postage directly onto envelopes,
labels,
even plain paper.
Then hand it to your mail carrier.
There's no guesswork.
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the
exact postage you need for any class of male.
You'll never have to go to the post office again.
Personally,
I use stamps.com to send out my posters,
my DVDs,
whatever the hell I'm going to be selling at the end of my shows.
I am a moron and I have had zero problems with stamps.com if I can figure it
out.
So can you,
don't be intimidated by any new technology.
That stuff is great.
Right now.
Use My last name burpee.
You are for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
just click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Burp.
You are that stamps.com and burr.
Alright,
and that's it.
That's the uh,
that's the,
uh,
what did he say that the uh,
the fucking,
uh,
the advertising for this week?
Um,
all right,
back to the,
uh,
back to the podcast.
So evidently in the soccer world,
um,
the u s is going to be playing Belgium tomorrow in World Cup soccer.
And I got to tell you,
it's going to be a bud burner though.
You know what's amazing?
We advanced to the next round and we lost.
We lost to Germany.
We lost to the crouch.
Okay.
You know we lost to a country that didn't get,
couldn't tell that Hitler maybe was a little bit off.
That's what we did.
That's what we did on this weekend.
Now you got,
you can't tell me in any other fucking sport
when you lose to the country that gave us Adolf Hitler,
you are out of that tournament but not in World Cup soccer.
We literally lost the game and I was sitting there go,
fuck.
We lost the game and all of a sudden our whole team is smiling and clapping.
You know,
we lost to the country that gave us Rudolph Hess.
and what happens,
we all start fucking clapping
and somehow,
I dunno,
we ended up advancing because Turks and Caicos last a Cucamonga.
So now we move on.
All right.
And to be fair to Germany,
I got to tell you,
I don't think anything makes up for the Nazis,
but damn close is the Mercedes Benz and the Porsche.
I got to tell you their cars,
the cars are fucking incredible.
And by the way,
if you guys want to write into the podcast,
um,
and you want to,
you know,
send in a question or maybe help me with some of my,
uh,
my World Cup football knowledge here.
Uh,
the email is bill at the m podcast.
Um,
that is the email and if you'd like to follow them on Monday morning podcast,
see all the links and all that type of shit,
just go to the MM,
uh,
at the MM podcast on Twitter.
Sorry.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
Um,
so somehow we made it to the next round to the round of 16.
Now as far as I know,
I don't think we've ever advanced beyond the round of 16.
Maybe back in the 1930s shit,
we maybe even want it.
I don't think we did back when they played soccer and they wore like suspenders,
the hold up their trousers,
you know,
people had homemade shoes.
Um,
I dunno.
Uh,
so anyways,
replaying Belgium,
and this is another one where I'm just like,
you know what?
How the fuck can we lose to a country that can't even come up with an original
flag?
Their flag is basically Germany's flag and they just turned it,
you know,
to the side rather than having the bars going horizontal,
they just haven't gone right side up.
As far as I know,
when I look at it,
that to me that's the German flag.
I didn't realize it's Belgium,
you know,
it's called the officially the Kingdom of Belgium.
Yeah.
It's a federal monarchy in western Europe.
It's a monarchy.
So I mean is it even a goddamned country?
The fuck is a monarchy.
Isn't that when like one guy is somehow running everything?
A monarchy is a form of government in which sovereignty is actually a nominally
nominally embodied in a single individual.
Yeah.
The monarch.
So rather than a president,
so who do you have?
Okay.
Now Jesus,
look at it.
All of these fucking people.
Good Lord.
Okay,
that's not a fun page.
Um,
so who the fuck's your monarch?
So no matter what this guy does,
this dude stays in office.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
There is no fucking way we're losing to this,
this,
this kind of day.
They got one guy,
they make big,
you know,
it's overrated.
Belgium bear at least the shift that we have over here.
It's too God damn sweet.
These fucking hipsters walking around drinking it,
these giant bottles of the shit.
I'm just kidding.
I would actually love to go to Belgium and uh,
but as far as I know,
John Claude van Damme and the battle of the bulge,
those are the two things I know about Belgium.
And now I know that you guys,
you live under a monarchy.
Um,
historically Belgium,
the Netherlands and Luxembourg.
We're also known as the low countries.
Oh Shit.
If fucking they would demand trash talking.
You've,
which used to cover a somewhat larger area.
Wait,
what are the low countries makes up a coastal region in Northwestern Europe.
Okay.
Oh,
that's great.
So that's,
that's considered low to me geographically.
When I look at a map and you talking low,
that's the southern hemisphere.
I know.
I'm a moron.
A who gives a shit?
You know,
I really thought it was going to be able to look at this guide.
The ampage here on Youtube.
On Youtube.
I mean on a Wikipedia.
Yeah.
So what have they done here?
History.
Politics,
geography,
economy,
military.
Okay.
Now at some point they had to be running shit.
Some point everybody was running shit,
right?
Military,
the Belgian armed forces have about 47,000 active trips.
All that's adorable.
In 2010 Belgium's defense budget total.
3.95 euros.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
I know like 10 comedians that could pay for their entire military budget.
Those fucking Dj's,
those God Damn Djs,
they could,
they get to like five shows over there.
That's how,
that's how you survive when the bubble bursts on the fucking Edm,
uh,
music bubble
there is,
you just during this time,
you donate to the Belgium armed forces and you pay for him and then you'll be,
you'll be like David Hasselhoff in Germany.
Like you'd just be famous forever.
A Jerry Lewis and France.
Anyways,
he said they are organized into one unified structure,
which consists of four main components,
land component or the army.
Okay.
The air force,
the navy and the medical component.
All right.
The effects of World War II made collective security a priority.
Well,
Jesus Christ,
you didn't figure that out.
If the first one even France made the Maginot line just didn't work so well.
They just kind of flew over it.
Um,
in March,
1948,
Belgium signed the Treaty of Brussels and then join NATO in 1948.
However,
the integration of the armed forces into NATO did not begin until after the
Korean War.
The Belgians along with the Luxembourg government
sent it detachment of battalion strength of 50 Korean.
Yeah.
They're basically not doing shit over.
There is no fucking white dude.
If you only got three and a half million people in your armed forces are,
y'all used to only spend that much money,
you get 48,000 people and you're armed forces.
I mean,
that's such a small pool to pick from,
dude.
This is going to be an absolute fucking disgrace if we lose.
This is like losing to,
they've liked the United States.
Okay.
The collective talent of the United States played like Kentucky.
There's no way we could,
I'm definitely watching this fucking game.
It's on at 9:00 AM tomorrow.
I think I'll be flying.
You know what?
I guess I've got to sign up for Hulu plus over there.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get back to Vegas out here.
I uh,
had a great time last night.
I did a surprise,
not so surprised.
Um,
guest spot
and uh,
on the fucking
what the fuck?
The uh,
the all the all tour.
Sorry guys.
You can you tell I've been drinking again.
Drinking again.
Oh baby.
I'm drinking again.
I went 73 fucking days with that,
without the booze
and uh,
Versie Bart,
nick in law had all came in Saturday night after,
um,
my second show over here at the Mirage.
And uh,
I came back to my room and I was waiting for them.
They were on their way up.
Kevin Shay opened for me.
All right,
so all,
all the fucking maniacs.
We're out here and I'm sitting there with the lovely Nia and she's going,
I'm tired.
I'm like,
I'm tired too.
I swear to God,
if these guys weren't in town,
I would just go to bed and they showed up.
We had a couple of drinks and some cigars sitting on the table and I go to my
wife,
hey,
you know,
like,
well it's just,
we're just going to go outside and smoked a cigar.
I'll be back in a couple hours or whatever.
And that was like it.
Okay.
I don't know what that was.
That was probably just a little bit after midnight.
Okay.
And I don't,
you know,
I started drinking and I just became that guy,
that guy who just wants to keep going and does not want to go home and uh,
Barton English joke and said what we did was basically they could have shot a
commercial for Las Vegas is what we did.
Um,
I hate to say it.
We did an,
we just did old school Vegas shit that was not old school when I first started
coming to Vegas,
but I've been out here for 15 years and like the new school's going to their Dj
Shit.
So
I even know what the fuck we did.
We some,
I think we ended up over the Venetian
and uh,
we were already smoking cigars.
I don't really even remember.
I was just pounding.
Well,
where are we?
I played roulette somewhere
and I made money and I cashed out.
Then we went over to the v Venetian.
I remember playing craps,
throwing the dice.
Okay.
And it just kept going.
Hey,
instead of yelling,
and everybody's saying,
I'm throwing numbers over here.
Right.
I just started throwing and I did what I always did.
I bet the 68 in the past bar,
I should have bet the point.
I hit the point twice.
I threw like fucking,
I dunno,
1215 numbers in a row.
You know,
I was
bullshit,
man.
I had like five bucks on each fucking thing or whatever I made and I made a
couple hundred bucks cause I was too drunk to realize like,
Phil,
you know what you're feeling it,
why not throw down a little bit more,
but I didn't.
I just remember people on the other end of the table,
well going,
hey,
you're built bar.
You're thrown die.
I go,
that's right.
They're buttoned down.
Throwing numbers,
Talk Shit.
Oh it was Alvin.
A hell of a type tip and people doing what you're supposed to do.
Laughing my ass off.
I made money.
I went back over,
cashed out.
I had like fucking three $100 bills in my pocket.
I have just starting off with my old hybrid,
so I guess it was up 200 bucks.
Now all of a sudden this shady dude comes up to us who had this weird little
sodas,
zipper scar on his nose and he's handing us a fucking flyer.
All wait,
somewhere in there.
I met these two agent chicks and I talked them back into their dreams.
I can't answer that.
I'm just one girl.
She was an accountant.
She wanted to be in fashion.
And I was like,
so go do that.
He's like,
do you really think I carrot Mike?
Yeah,
you totally can just keep your day job and just start working on the fashion
thing and then eventually fashion thing will surpass your other thing.
She was like,
you're so awesome.
And all I'm thinking in my head is,
this is why that fucking
was able to buy where the Houston Rockets used to play and go in there and talk
about Jesus.
What the fuck is that guy's name?
You know that guy,
you know?
Oh,
what is his fucking name?
He's got the squinty eyes.
He closes his eyes and he sits there.
You know,
Jesus wants you to have a popsicle.
He wants you to,
all you gotta do is just tell people what they,
what they want to hear.
And I was totally sincere.
Okay.
When I told this woman to go follow her dreams,
but I didn't really give her any sort of concrete plan.
All I did was just tell her that she could do it and it made it feel good.
So I did do a good thing,
but you know something I,
if the bottom falls out of standup comedy,
that's what I'm going to,
I'm going to turn into a motivational speaker.
Okay.
I would absolutely crush it because I already know how to make people laugh and
then rather than being a negative content,
I would totally turn it.
I would finally take off like,
you know,
you don't want to,
spider man wears that black suit and he can't control it and he starts acting
like a cunt,
you know,
starts talking shit to women and spraying web web juice in their face.
Then he goes back to the classic red and blue and then he's like,
oh,
I'm sorry about that,
sweetie.
Let me get that.
Oh my God,
the fucking iPhone.
I get it.
I heard the first fucking won
Jesus fucking Christ.
Why does it do that?
It ranks and then you don't pick it up.
I literally pushed the fucking button to say,
I don't want to,
you know,
it's funny,
some Dj that boom,
boop,
boop.
They could turn that into a hit song.
And if you'd be,
you know,
like they could blend that with guns and roses,
whatever the fuck it,
that's sweet child of mine.
Which by the way,
I heard the blending of that last night at this bar that I was at and I
literally thought that somebody had put on two fucking stereos at the same time.
Stereos.
That's how old I am.
And I gotta be honest with you,
it sounded like absolute shit that was not a good example of that.
Uh,
it's fucking annoys the shit out of me when young kids think that,
that's fucking amazing.
When somebody blends this album with that album and they can't fucking believe
it,
like,
Oh shit,
how did they do that?
It's like,
well,
you're basically,
you find two songs that are the same tempo,
you know,
that's all you need.
If they're the same tempo,
they'll all fit.
That's it.
So that's your homework this week.
Some up and coming Dj,
I want you to have a hit.
I want you to get out here to Vegas and starts vacuuming up all this money that
the thrown at these djs out here.
Take that fucking boop,
boop,
whatever the fuck that is,
you know,
and blend that with the Lawrence Welk,
Winchester Cathedral or whatever the fuck you want to do with it.
I don't,
I don't give a shit.
Um,
the hell was I talking about?
God dammit.
I was on my way to talking about something here
that gives a fuck.
Let's just,
let's just,
uh,
let's just plow ahead here.
Shall We?
Um,
by the way,
I've mentioned this before for both men and women.
There is a certain age will you just have to,
you got to act your age when it comes to dressing.
Okay.
Like right now,
I am in my mature years.
Okay.
And women my age are in their elegant years.
When you get past a certain age as a woman,
you should dress elegantly.
Do not try to dress like hotly,
I guess is the word.
And I should not try to dress like I'm still a fucking stud.
You know,
like,
I don't want to take a nap every day in the afternoon,
like after 1130.
I don't feel like just going back to the bed,
the bedroom,
you know,
the hotel room,
whatever the fuck I'm trying to say.
Right?
Like I really want to stay out all fucking night
owl shit.
I didn't finish that fucking story.
So this guy with a Goddamn zipper stark scar on his fucking nose,
he convinces us to go to a titty bar,
which really wasn't difficult.
And next thing you know,
we're in this fucking titty bar and on.
These women were really God damn aggressive.
Like the second you sat down,
one of them sat in your lap and I was like,
it was really,
I'd be honest with you,
it's fucking suffocating.
I actually just kind of like,
Hey,
can you fucking let me just get my bearings here
before you put,
quit trying to shake your tits?
They're fake.
They're not moving.
All right,
what do you do next?
Shake your elbow.
Um,
so anyways,
we're in this fucking place.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I mean,
we're all guys,
we don't give a fuck.
Next thing you know,
it's like six o'clock in the God damn morning.
Six something.
We came walking out,
it was broad daylight and I'm sitting there like,
the only thing I can relate it to was when I was playing up in Alaska,
when,
uh,
when it was at one of those times a year where it had like 22 hours of sunlight
and you were inside the club and you drink it.
And it's about two in the morning.
Like,
all right guys,
I'm tired.
I'm going to bed.
And then you would walk outside,
you'd open the door into broad daylight and immediately give body's clock.
You would wake up,
he said at two in the afternoon,
two,
two at night.
It seemed like two in the is
the only way I could describe it.
And I walked out and,
uh,
all I heard was Kevin Chaise.
Maniacal fucking laugh at like how light it,
it was out.
Um,
so that was my,
basically,
that was my first night out here.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I'm still recovering from it.
And that was two goddamn days ago.
Last night after a show,
I was just like,
I sat down and I got something to eat.
I had one Budweiser and then I went to bed and I was fucking psyched to come
back and go to bed.
So that goes back to what I was talking about.
So I have to dress maturely.
All right now,
like I was ever a guy walking around a tank top.
I didn't,
I didn't have any fucking a pigment,
you know?
But I gotta tell you,
you go out on the pool.
Some people,
I don't know if they just have,
they just,
they can't see it or if they just don't give a fuck some of the shit that people
wear it down by God damn pool.
I mean
it's just like,
can you put that all of that shit away?
Can you put it away?
Half the people at the pool,
it should be wearing like one of those bathing suits from the roaring twenties,
you know,
where it was.
Basically,
it was kind of a mechanic suit like that.
Fonzie used to wear that one z zip up,
except you would cut the sleeves off and you would cut the legs off.
That's what guys would wear.
And women wear the same thing and they'd have a little frilly thing going around
the outside.
Now
it's unreal,
man.
Oh Jesus.
And my generation,
oof.
It's ugly.
The tramp stamps,
the Barb wire tattoo around your arm.
It's just a,
it's not a good fucking look.
It's just not a good look.
But anyway,
so let's get,
let's get to some of the reeds here today because I'm actually going to go out
with the fellas today and I think we're going to go shoot machine guns because
why wouldn't you?
You know,
either that I'm going to look at some fucking classic cars,
one or the other.
All right,
let's get on with the,
uh,
the reach for this week.
Uh,
books.
Oh Jeez.
Now you guys know better than to bring up books to me.
You really do.
Right.
All right.
Billy Shakespeare and joys your last recommendation because I'm also a World War
II buff.
I'm currently reading Kevin Pollock's biography.
I have to lighten things up once in a while.
All right.
Also,
you should have him on your podcast or be on his video podcasts.
Um,
well shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
if a fucking movie star wants me to be on his podcast,
yeah,
I would do that.
Anyways.
He says,
my question is,
do you have any new book recommendations?
Uh,
fuck.
I saw one the other day that made me want to read it.
What the hell was it?
Ah,
fuck.
I Dunno.
I can't keep track of it at the amount of shit that's is interesting.
Interesting me right now.
MMM.
Like now that I'm going to be home for July,
I really want to get in good shape and uh,
so I'm thinking about,
yeah,
you don't try to go veggie for a little bit,
learn how to eat that way and then gradually work,
meet back in.
But just in general,
just eating way more healthy than I than I have been eating in the past.
But I got to tell you last night that burger and fries off Jesus.
Was that good?
I mean,
is there anything fucking better than just a straight up fucking cheeseburger?
Yeah.
With some French fries?
Well done.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay.
I mean,
I,
I swear if I was on death row,
I think that that would be my meal Burger and fries.
Well done.
And that's some fucking mint chocolate chip ice cream,
you know?
And then what's hilarious is as they're walking you down to the electric chair,
you know,
you
play a place I'll do,
or that you already got me in a cage.
MMM.
I don't know what I'd do.
I'd probably,
yeah,
I think that maybe that's what I would have.
Oh yeah.
I'd probably have to have a beer too.
And a great glass.
That is so weird that you get the last fucking meal.
You know,
you obviously did something so fucking horrific that the other person did get a
last meal.
Okay.
Why do,
why?
Why do we do that?
MMM.
So anyways,
yeah,
I've,
I've been looking at all kinds of shit.
Uh,
what is a foe?
What is the book?
Yeah.
I should've,
I should've wrote it down.
It was yet again,
some new thing that interests me.
And it was a great book about the whole kind of history of it.
Yeah.
MMM.
Fuck.
What was it?
Yeah,
whatever.
If I remember,
I'll post it.
MMM.
Well that was really a fucking Dick Tease,
wasn't it?
I wasn't able to remember.
All right.
You want me to call up to just answer it somehow.
What I'm,
what I'm really into right now,
what I'm trying to learn how to do is I'm trying to like all I know how to make
his heart attack food.
So I actually looked up a thing here.
Keenan was salad light and healthy summer recipe.
I got to wait.
Here was,
everybody calls me a fucking twinkle toes.
Um,
it actually looks fucking delicious.
It's a high source of protein and I got to tell you who the fuck doesn't want to
be in shape.
You know,
and this is all of this stuff.
This is,
you know,
be a fuck a man.
Eat a cheeseburger.
You're fucking dose,
right?
Yeah.
But a keen was salad,
but I'm telling you,
if you make this shit,
you just got it sitting in your fridge and red is,
you're starting to get hungry.
If you just shovel some of that down your throat,
all the bad urge is
yeah.
Are Now put it back and you're like,
oh thank God,
thank God I did that.
Thank God I did that and I didn't fucking have the waffle fries,
you know,
on top of fucking pancakes or whatever the fuck you gonna have.
Um,
no I really want to,
uh,
you know,
rather than doing like a fad diet,
my wife,
you know,
she came out here for a couple of days and now she just went back cause now I'm
hanging out with the fellows and um,
she left this us weekly magazine
and
there's a picture of j Lo on the cover says j Lo's new body at 44.
The single star kickstarted her diet with a 22 day cleanse.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I ain't doing that now.
Friends are already fixing her up with DWT.
Ss makes whatever the fuck that means.
Dances with the stars.
Um,
anyways,
first of all,
her face,
she doesn't even look the same and she looks slightly Asian now.
MMM.
But anyways,
she uh,
she did some sort of Veggie diet and they had the website to it.
So I clicked on the link.
Don't,
I wouldn't have vegan thing.
I want to learn how to do this shit.
I'd like to do,
I'd like to date a fellow from dancing with the stars.
Oh.
With his little shorts.
Ah,
C'mon ob.
I'll spin you around the dance floor.
They had cliffy.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I look it up and I go to the website and it's a bunch of those fucking stupid
protein bars.
I don't know shit about nutrition.
I'm going to tell you those fucking protein bars and that God damn whey powder
and all of that,
none of that shit is good for you.
I'm going to go out on a fucking limb and say that there's going to be a bunch
of studies already saw Dr. Ross where they was saying that all that protein
power on that way,
shit,
it's not regulated by the FDA food,
drug administration or whatever.
Right.
And even if it was
half the fucking people who sit on the board of that used to work for like fruit
loops and I know I'm overly simplifying that,
but they basically have the nuts running the nuthouse like they've completely
infiltrated all of that Shit,
these evil ass fucking corporations.
Um Oh shit.
That's what I can,
that's what I can
commend reading.
I got this magazine and um,
it's just talking about,
you know,
basically the 10 worst corporations out there.
And for me,
dude,
this is the real deal.
Shit,
I got to hit pause cause I,
I want to show you guys his magazine here.
Where the fuck is my recorder?
Hang on,
hang on,
hang on.
Okay,
I'm back through the magic.
So the magic of technology and hitting the pause button.
I am back.
I'm putting on my headphones.
Hang on.
Here we go.
So the name of the magazine is called ad busters.
Terrible fucking name.
I understand that.
But uh,
this just has like a,
you know,
it says something dumb and this issue of ad busters,
we're going to do something that hasn't been done for over a hundred years.
We're going to kill off one corporation.
So already you're like,
oh,
GHGs and it says which one will it be and blah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
but beyond that,
like they actually think that they're going to kill off a fucking corporation.
It's like,
no,
you're not.
No,
This corporation is going to kill you and me way before you're able to kill it
off.
Um,
okay.
Does this match this magazine?
Absolutely fucking fascinating cover to cover and of all the shit and how out of
control some of these,
these,
these top corporations are not saying they're all bad,
but I am telling you like,
okay,
this,
this right here,
to me,
this is the real deal where everybody's on fucking TV and they sit there and
they're talking about Obama.
This or George Bush that and Democrat,
Republican,
Conservative,
liberal,
all of that is a bunch of fucking,
it's just,
it's bullshit.
It's all bullshit.
Okay?
The president makes 400 fucking grand a year.
He gets another hundred grand for like food and travel,
something like that.
Okay.
And he's supposed to somehow keep in control.
People who are getting $10 million bonuses,
all right?
This shit right here and these guys here,
these all these corporations,
all these banks and all this type stuff,
they got money on both sides of the ball.
It doesn't make a fucking bit of difference,
okay?
If the president is a Democrat to president as a Republican,
if the president is a libertarian,
it's president's a man,
a woman,
White,
black,
Asian,
it doesn't fucking make a pick a bit of difference.
They make 400 fucking grand a year.
All right?
And their job is basically to get yelled at.
That's their fucking job,
to get blamed for everything that's going wrong.
And it's up.
I night 100% fucking believe that.
And if you don't believe that,
I think that you Europe,
yeah,
I,
I can't help you.
I can't fucking help you.
You,
you're an adult and you still believe in Santa Claus.
That's how I look at.
So that is what I am reading and that right there,
I'm going to read that shit and that's going to go into my five stupid fucking
brain.
And uh,
you know,
I already have a nice chunk that I'm starting to build for my next hour and a
nice,
basically that's how I do it.
I just fucking,
I just,
I'll read shit on a,
Keenan was salad and then I'll read why Exxon is the most evil corporation
fucking ever.
And then I just sort of mash them together like a DJ where,
where,
Oh my God.
How did he do that?
He put Keanu with salad next to Exxon.
Way,
way.
Whether there's a better blood.
I'm
sorry I don't have his fucking,
that was even annoying to me and I love myself.
All right.
Dating a girl who was very hot and very,
very dumb.
Hey Billy banana split.
I have an issue at some point I'm going to fucking list all the names,
the nicknames you guys have given me throughout the weeks here.
Um,
I have an issue with the girl.
I recently started dating and I need some major advice.
I'm 25 years old and I met a 21 year old girl in my city.
She's way out of my league.
Don't have a say that.
Don't ever say that about yourself.
All right.
Your self esteem is not at the level that you need to date this woman.
All right,
well maybe just be a nice,
she's way out of my league,
but it's extremely fun to hang out with and can drink with the best of my guy
friends.
I used to question,
I used to get questions from my guy friends like,
dude,
seriously,
how did you get her a Europe big headed booze hound with the gut.
And she's actually good looking though.
This is great so far.
He goes,
well I think I may have found my answer.
She is extremely dumb.
Uh,
man,
that's like you find a classic car and the fucking engine has seized.
You go to start it up and it just doesn't run.
You got to look at,
look at this,
look at it,
look at that grill.
Anyways.
Well I think I may have found my answer.
She's extremely dumped.
For example,
at her work,
a tanning place.
She does word searches from kids,
kids books.
Oh No.
You know the kind you find on a kid's menu at the,
at the all of Gad.
Um,
oh my God.
She couldn't follow the plot of the movie.
The sandlot.
She's showing more and more signs that she is about as smart as your average
eighth grader,
including not knowing what the word punctuation meant.
Should I look past it and keep dating her or move on to a girl I can actually
have age appropriate conversations with.
I have a,
I'm having a lot of fun with her,
but this is starting to worry me.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
All right.
Um,
you given me conflict.
I know she's beautiful and all that type of stuff.
And then,
but then also you're saying that
you are having a lot of fun with her.
How,
what is the fun?
Is She legitimately fun to be with?
It makes you smile,
you know,
it makes you feel a little bit lighter.
You know,
you don't got the weight of the world on your shoulders.
I mean that's a big thing.
But,
um,
if you're having fun with it cause she's hot and you think she's out of your
league and you're enjoying having sex with her,
um,
look,
as I saw it down at the Vegas Pool Countless Times this weekend,
uh,
looks at the first thing that go.
So in the end of it,
you're going to want to have somebody that you can talk to and you can hang out
with,
um,
you can be friends with and that type of thing.
So like,
look,
if she's a little ditsy or whatever,
I mean,
okay,
that's not the worst thing.
I mean,
if,
if maybe that's what you need,
someone's a little bit lighter,
but like,
if she literally doesn't know what the word punctuation means,
um,
okay.
I,
you know,
I understand your concerns because when you,
if you marry and you have kids,
like half of that brain is going into your kid.
Like,
I don't think I would want to be the smartest person in my family.
I would like everybody to kind of be on the same playing field.
Uh,
and that is the thing.
That is the thing when you go to marry somebody is uh,
you know,
whatever brain they have,
whatever skills they have,
like that's going to be 50%.
Like I've said that before,
like with like Michael Jordan's son,
like I bet he got a lot of shit cause he wasn't as good as his dad.
And it's like,
that's not my fault that I'm 50% my mom,
you know,
it's like drugs that have been stepped on.
It's not pure cocaine anymore.
It's got a bunch of ex lacks in there.
So I would say,
um,
it's beginning to worry.
Well,
MMM,
that doesn't sound like you're ready to break up with her yet.
I would,
uh,
I would keep an eye on those concerns.
I don't know,
but you don't want to break her heart or anything.
You know what dude?
You know what you thinking.
Come on.
You know what you're thinking.
Either you could look past it because she's fun and she makes your day lighter,
which is the greatest guy damn thing you can find,
you know,
or it's really bugging you,
but she's just hot and you're staying with the because of that.
But you know,
when I was at the down the casino,
this last night when I was at Caesars,
I saw like a bunch of old people there and I saw a couple of old people walking
by and they still,
one of them had his arm around his wife and other one was holding their hands.
And I remember thinking like that going,
that's fucking awesome.
That right there is what life is all about.
If you fucking can somehow get that,
you know,
the end of your life,
you still love the person that you're with,
you can go to Vegas and have a good time.
You know,
it did it.
You hit the fucking lottery.
So good luck to you sir.
Um,
I hope,
I dunno.
I,
I hope it works out for Yam root for your hair.
We got pot smoking stepson.
Hey that Billy sizzle chest.
I write a Jerky boys referenced and I like it.
If you and the lovely Nia would address my question,
I would be honored.
Well,
she's back in La and I'm hanging out with the fellas.
Uh,
I am the stepfather to a troubled in slightly delayed 16 year old think toddler
mentality mentality,
tantrums with only a slightly more advanced intellect.
I confronted him last night after I smelled it.
The strength,
distinct aroma of weed coming from
hang on a VRC.
I'm wrapping up my podcast.
Me Call you in about 10 minutes.
All right.
All right,
cool.
Um,
shed if you will,
in the lovely Nia,
blah,
blah.
Um,
I confronted him a him last night after I smelled a distinct aroma of weed
coming from the basement.
Oh,
Jesus.
Previously I'd questioned him after he had mass it with,
uh,
with Cologne,
which he always denied.
He finally admitted his use and that he had been buying from a classmate,
his mother,
who am I loved dearly and with whom I have two kids of my own ages.
Six and eight seems to think that this is not a bad thing given what we have
endured with him.
Uh,
I won't go into all the details,
but the cops have been to our house three times in the last six months for his
violent behavior,
breaking shit in our house and threatening suicide.
Oh My god,
though I think you need to talk to a professional here,
tackling his mother and spitting in our faces.
His Dad beat him physically two years ago,
which is a,
resulted in him cutting all,
all ties with that side of the family.
She objects to the prescribed medication and thinks that we could be the answer
to mellow out his ADHD or Asperger's.
I think it would only further complicate the PR problem and lead to a harder
drug use.
We've been to multiple doctors and counselors,
which have pretty much all suggested medication.
We've even tried eastern medicine and now you don't have all the details,
but am I right in my thinking?
I told him if he tests positive,
he will be out of the house.
Ah,
Jesus,
dude,
this is way beyond my shit.
Okay.
You need to talk to a professional.
But having said that,
if you want my opinion knowing full well that I am not a doctor,
I don't fucking know what I'm talking about.
Um,
I think this kid needs,
uh,
some understanding rather than threats at this point.
Uh,
I granted,
I know he's attacked you physically and spit in your face and all that type of
shit.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know what I would,
I mean personally I would rather he smoked weed then went on some fucking
medicine because all that shit is new and they don't know what it does to you
yet.
And uh,
I'd be afraid if it was going to just kind of make them catatonic.
Um,
so I would really research whatever the hell are you going to have him put into
his body.
But like,
I don't think that his acting out is crazy.
I mean,
can you imagine that like your parents get divorced and trying to have a
relationship with your dad and your dad beats the shit out of you?
It,
you're the only father who's supposed to love you unconditionally.
Beats the shit out of you.
Like,
I don't,
I don't even know how the Hell I could wrap my head around that.
Um,
and then he probably resent you because he wants his real dad,
but then his real dad does love him.
The kids in a hell of a place mentally.
Um,
I know you have to be stern with them,
but I,
I would maybe try to talk to them and maybe you could do this considering you're
not his real dad.
Like,
just try to talk to
a man demand and,
uh,
just try to build some sort of relationship where,
it kind of opens it up where you guys can actually sit down and maybe you can
share some of the shit that happened to him when you were a kid that
disappointed you.
I don't,
I don't know if it's going to pale in comparison to his shit,
but a dude that's really beyond what the fuck I'm at.
I can't help you necessarily,
but that,
but,
um,
I wouldn't be closed off to weed though.
You know,
I would much rather have a kid in mind smoking weed than to be on some sort of
medicine.
MMM.
Look basically in life there's a line.
Okay?
And you have the,
this illegal and legal,
all right?
But they're both the same.
You know,
like the smartest mobsters in the world went legit.
And what they did was they got onto the legal side of stealing.
So now you don't have to hide your money.
You don't have to wash it.
You don't have to come up with all this shit.
You don't have to have leg breakers.
Okay?
You don't need leg burgers anymore because the law is on your side.
When you steal,
you have the cops,
you have the court system,
you have all of that shit that we'll just go over and pick this person up and
handle it.
Um,
and you can go out and go buy a big giant fucking house and you don't have to
worry about people going,
where did you get the money for that?
Okay.
And that exists with extortion that exist with a like loan sharking all of that
banking is just legalized loan sharking it's all the same fucking scam.
And they don't need leg breakers anymore because they got the cops cause it's
legal.
So the same thing is going on with like drugs and all of that type of shit.
These guys are legal drug dealers.
So now they don't have to have,
you know,
fucking machine guns and all this type of shit looking out for the cops and all
that that are on the legal side of this stuff.
And that shit is,
uh,
you know,
like I mentioned before,
and the FDA,
you have people on that board that used to work for these fucking drug companies
and you know,
they get kickbacks,
look at these fucking presence,
but presence makes four or 500 grand fucking year.
And all of them are multimillionaires.
And all of them at the end of their careers,
they go out and they give speeches for like $1 million a fucking night.
What the fuck can you say in an hour
that's worth $1 million?
You're giving a speech,
you should almost have to pay somebody 1000 bucks to listen to her.
Cause it's gonna be boring as shit.
But that's basically,
that is the legal kickback,
you know,
hey,
push this through.
Look the other way so we can make this zillion dollars and get our yachts and
then when you fucking leave office,
we will then hire you at our company to talk for an hour.
We won't even listen when we looking at our fucking iPhones and when it's done,
we're going to give you a sack of fucking money.
I mean that's
basic what's going on.
So when you go into the getting your kid on drugs,
you have to understand that that's the world that you're going into.
And even though that it's legal and everybody has lab coats and they got degrees
on the walls,
it's,
it's still a filthy,
filthy fucking business and it's getting fucking worse.
And that's why I'm telling you,
you're seeing people Odie and again,
the way you did back in the 60s when the fucking,
the first sort of like pills,
that wave of pills came out and everybody,
like doctors would just prescribe them,
oh you got a nervous condition.
And then they didn't know not to take them with alcohol.
It's like all these fucking people who are out dean out there like 10 years ago,
like wouldn't have oh deed.
Okay.
In that way because all of a sudden there's these new fucking drugs and they're
all coming through and they're all getting pushed through because it's a bunch
of fucking money at stake.
Okay.
And I know I'm a moron,
but that's basically what's going on.
So I would um,
okay.
And then I fell on the other side where weed is becoming legal.
It's becoming safer with like,
okay,
like if you want you to,
to smoke weed,
like I would get them like a,
uh,
I get them a vaporizer.
So it's just the shit that he needs to get them high and if it mellows them out
and he's not going to flip the fuck out because,
okay.
What weeds doing whatever drug they're going to give you is kind of,
kind of do the same thing,
right?
Just make this kid fucking relaxed.
Yeah,
I know.
That's,
that's my 2 cents.
That's probably worth half a cent,
but that's what I think on that shit.
All right.
Fresh start.
Yo,
Billie Jean.
I can,
I can really use your advice.
I'm 19 years old and have been a wreck since I graduated.
I can't land a job to save my life and all my friends,
all my friendships are down in the dumps.
My family,
uh,
my family is very religious,
so talking to them about this issue will go nowhere,
but Jesus and God,
Oh,
we'll go nowhere except,
but Jesus and God.
Okay,
so I'm asking you because at least you can give me a whole new look.
I really want a fresh new start in a new town,
but don't know how to make a fresh start.
I'm a loner type of guy because growing up I had no one to talk to because my
parents worked a lot.
So they would leave me at home alone after I came from school and I have no
siblings and most of my high school I got treated like,
Shit.
Jesus Christ,
dude,
I could really use your type advice,
what to do to get a fresh start to help me.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
All right,
here we go.
Okay.
So the fact that you're a loner,
that's actually a good thing.
In a way.
It's hurting you in certain areas.
But I also can help you as far as like being comfortable being alone actually
makes you strong.
All right?
But there's like with anything,
you have to do it in moderation.
So what I'm worried with you is you're going to go out and you want a fresh
start.
You thinking,
I got to get out of this town because they have all these bad memories here.
So I need a fresh start.
That's a great thing to do.
All right?
But when you go,
if you keep the same mindset of isolating yourself and all that type of stuff,
you're going to,
you're gonna if you don't change a game plan,
it'd be like if you were a football coach and you lost the game in Florida,
okay,
you lost to the Miami Dolphins and next week you're going all the way to Seattle
to play the Seahawks,
but you're going to use the exact same game plan.
You're gonna fucking lose again.
So,
uh,
if I was you,
I would try to open up more.
Try to get some new friends as far as,
mmm.
I would,
I would try to do something social,
something that you like if you're into sports,
join a softball league or something like that.
If you're end up fucking rock climbing,
join a rock climbing gym and I'm all over the board here,
but basically get involved in some sort of group activity and,
um,
I don't know,
an open up to your friends and just be honest to say,
listen man,
I'm trying to be more social.
All right.
I grew up by myself.
I didn't have a good experience and all this stuff.
He just told me,
you just tell people you don't dump it on them.
Like when you first fucking beat him,
just be matter of fact,
just me and yeah.
You know,
I gotta I gotta break out of this because someday I'd like to,
uh,
have,
you know,
wife and family or whatever,
but,
um,
as far as,
well,
I only way I can relate to moving and having a,
yeah,
a fresh new start.
Uh,
I would just compare to
when I moved from my parent's house down in New York City,
what I basically did was I paid down all of my debt.
MMM.
And this took me couple of years.
I paid it all down and then I started saving up money.
And,
um,
so when I moved down to New York,
I had like this nest egg and I didn't have the stress and I could actually just,
you know,
jump in my piece of shit.
83 Ford Ranger on a weight that they had burned down by that and went down in a
fucking u haul.
That's right.
And I just moved someplace
and uh,
start it over again.
Um,
I would encourage you to get,
try to force yourself to come out of your shell.
And you know what?
You can do that in your hometown.
You can actually create some,
uh,
some good memories from when you're there.
Uh,
you basically,
you have all that power.
You just don't realize it because you're young,
you know,
and you were a little kid and shit was bad and you don't have any frame of
reference.
And your parents didn't give you any tools to learn how to overcome shit to
think positively and all that type of stuff.
So I do whatever the fuck he could.
I would read self help books.
I would just flood myself with positive thoughts and pay attention to what my
brain was telling me.
And you turn that minus sign into a plus sign.
That's kind of what you gotta do.
You gotta beat the shit out of that negative voice cause you kind of stuck in
this Rut is what I would guess.
Um,
but the great thing is you're totally in control and you could fucking turn it
around and uh,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It's a bitch took me a,
it took me a long time to become the positive cunt that I am right today.
But to learn how to make a keynote was salad.
All right,
but not least is the last one here.
Fat Shaming won't work.
A Billy bench press.
MMM.
Uh,
here's my conundrum and I need your help and maybe the help of the lovely Nia on
how to handle a situation with my wife.
My wife has been really down lately about her weight.
Uh,
she's probably put on 20 pounds in the past two years and is having trouble
getting rid of it before Nia jumps all over me.
Jeez.
Nia has a rep now,
half a jumping all over people.
Um,
let me state that,
not once have I made an issue,
made this an issue and I tell her all the time,
she's beautiful.
All right.
Her weight gain is,
has not bothered me in the slightest as I barely noticed it.
Uh,
the problem is it has killed her attitude and it's been the subject slash
starting point for many fights.
I get blamed for not helping her,
even though I cook all healthy meals each day.
And when I call her out for not going to the gym enough or reading the wrong
shit,
she flips out.
Uh,
I try to stay as positive as I can,
but I can only take the verbal beating for so much more before I snap back and
tell her to stop blaming me for,
for her issues.
Any idea I can handle this situation?
Not sure who I should turn to,
but just,
uh,
but since she is a Gemini,
I thought you were the man for the job.
Thanks for everything and go fuck,
fuck yourself.
All right.
This is what I would do.
I would go out to your local cvs or even that,
maybe a card store where you can write something original.
All right?
And get something nice and loving on the cover.
And then you write from your heart how much you love her on the inside.
All right?
Something really quick.
And then you have an attached.
Nope.
And in the note,
you basically in a calm,
positive way,
express the fact that you're worried about her and you really want,
and it kills you that she's not happy and you love her.
So when she's not happy,
you're not happy and you want to help and you feel like basically where she's
at,
what you told me where she's at right now mentally is preventing you from
helping her and that you don't want to fight.
And this is the bottom I do.
It's only 20 pounds.
I mean,
that's a fucking joke.
You know,
she can get that off.
She just,
you know,
uh,
and obviously she wants to,
she sounds like a really strong person and most people who was strong,
you know,
their Achilles heel is the fact that they can't,
if they've been strong their whole life,
when there's a sign of weaknesses shown,
they get insecure and super defensive and there's nothing out there that is
going to show you a weakness or a flaw quicker than putting on weight because
it's not like,
okay,
this social issue that only comes up in a certain thing.
It's,
it's what you look like when you walk around.
And I'm sure most of the world is not even noticing or whatever,
but to her,
she sees it constantly.
So it's beyond just a pound thing.
It's the mental fucking weight on her head.
So,
um,
okay.
I would try to in a positive way,
opened the doors to some new line of communication and you really have to extra
be on your game because she might lash out at you.
Um,
even if she's receptive to this,
she might go back to the other thing.
And it's going to be really hard,
but you,
what you,
you have to do,
considering she's losing her cool,
is you have to stay extra cool to kind of balance it out and just sit there and
let her yell at you and say all type of stuff.
And it just,
if you just sit there and you say nothing,
okay.
And you just let her go and you just sitting there and you wait for it to finish
and you just,
rather than taking what she's saying personally,
okay,
you analyze it and just be like,
yeah,
right.
You know,
that's another example.
I'm not trying to nitpick.
That's another example right there where I am trying to help you and I need you
to stay calm,
blah,
blah.
Um,
you're not feeding the fire and it Kinda hopefully will just burn itself out.
And,
um,
fortunately she's a woman.
So I think she's going to be way more receptive to this line of,
uh,
line of attack because it's socially acceptable for a woman to be weak or admit
to weaknesses.
Where a guy,
you know,
we're supposed to be fucking John Wayne,
eating steaks a whole life,
sitting there with the fucking head won't go on.
It doesn't hurt,
you know,
so that's what I would do.
Um,
I would really,
um,
you know,
and then I'm not saying that you just have to sit there like a bitch either.
Like there will be times where you just have to sit up and just say,
listen,
uh,
you saying a bunch of mean things to me right now,
which is going to possibly cause me to say mean things back to you,
which I don't want to do.
So I'm going to go for a walk.
And when you calm down,
you know,
I would love to sit down this because I'm going to help you through this.
All right.
And just,
you know,
walk out as she's screaming and yelling at you and just go for a walk.
Okay.
You know,
just go for fucking walk.
Give her a good fucking two hours to calm down and then just come back.
Okay.
And sit down.
And I wouldn't even bring it up and I'd wait for her to bring it up.
Okay.
And then just let her say a shit.
And I,
and I,
if you just keep doing that,
I think hopefully that'll,
that'll get you to where you want to be.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
but I definitely wouldn't do the fat shame thing that I do on this,
this case scenario.
So anyways,
uh,
that is the podcast for this weekend.
Listen,
everybody,
I really want to promote this thing because it helps the all things comedy
network and he tickets that we sell.
Help us to run the,
uh,
the all things comedy network.
Um,
we do have some tickets left for the show tonight.
I'm sure the show tomorrow,
July 1st at nerd melt.
Um,
come on down.
It's going to be a great show.
Going to interact with the crowd.
We're going to be raising money for some fucking charity,
which I of course don't know.
I don't have the information,
but it's going to be great.
It's a great way to kick off your July.
Come on down to nerd melt on sunset.
We're going to have the link up and all that type of Crappola.
Um,
that is it.
And we'd love to sell out the first one.
Okay.
That is it.
That is a podcast for this week.
Go Fuck Yourself,
Belgium.
You make great beer.
You got a hell of a monarch,
but a,
your soccer team was going to lose tomorrow.
I'm calling it right now.
We're going to get to the round of eight and it's gonna take me at least three
days to get that information that it actually happened.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.